[Music]
the Canadian snowboarders let's talk
about them most to me like before the
Olympics they were talking a little
smack is that right yeah there was a
there's some smack talk on a shaun white
on twitter yeah do them yeah is that
you're talking about yeah that's what
I'm talking about those Canadians are
always acting so polite but then when it
gets real and gets a little intense
sometimes they let it all out I
definitely they definitely had it all
out on there so what are you in the
snowboarding community you're also laid
back and cool but do you ever when
someone's talking smack or getting out
of line do you ever beat them with your
snowboard that hasn't happened really I
mean maybe it like mountain high or
something usually we're like pretty cool
about everything and we don't really
like a fight yeah I think I'd get beat
up pretty bad if I tried fighting
something yeah it's not your style I
respect that you don't I'm not
suggesting that you beat anyone
yeah no I've got taken care of for you
no one talks smack about you guys you
brought something for me I'm I did maybe
put it out here just beforehand but I
wanted to show you we got this for you I
think it's a pretty deserving you get
your own snowboard beanie this is my
owns oh and it's got built in it's got
your hair
[Applause]
and get this going here yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
man that was I just had a great moment
there that was nasty
you look tall like Shawn light up there
man you know what I do have a Shawn
white vibe yeah you do you did you have
an angry villagers vibe
[Laughter]
[Applause]
trinkets waging the castle next door
I love this look it is easy this is how
I'm going out now I am never gonna take
this off God everywhere I go I'm just
gonna end people you'd be like Cohen
right I'd be like yeah guy on TV is not
this guy brothers from the move like
brothers yeah except I have no athletic
ability